this lady has done it all I'm talking
about Real Housewives of Atlanta star
kandi Burruss
she's got reality cameras following her
every single day and you know what I was
invited to just kick it with kandi see
what we did there in Atlanta and spend a
day in her life but as I found out that
life almost didn't include her fellow
housewives I honestly did not think you
were coming back this easy I honestly
thought about not coming really did you
cuz I I feel like because you do give
off this air if I'm so strong but you're
not fooling us because that broke me now
let's take repeated say I would judge
somebody the last season of the show
ended with some ugly accusations hurled
at the Grammy winning singer I don't
even want to bring up this to bring up
Phaedra like she and I Don Todd we
haven't talked she never really even
apologized to me I have nothing to say
in that situation this year are you out
of the drum on Housewives I'm not as
much involved in the drama on escape
show she's talking about her other Bravo
reality series escape still kickin it
reuniting her with her 90s R&B group
part of her busy day in the life
includes rehearsals yeah it seems like
it's a lot of drama there but it's more
it's different because it's more
personal
boy Kandi's drama-free zone
hanging with Sundays at the Atlanta home
she shares with husband Todd and their
blended family but her busy day isn't
over yet there's also the restaurant she
co-owns with Todd and runs with her mom
and us called the old late game
you have the show the group's back
together the restaurant I'm team no
sleep right now
[Music]
you